ribs baby
ribs it was one of the most disgusting
things i've ever eaten let's make some
whipped cream i love this i will never
buy croutons again thank you of course i
fed it to my kids personal growth how
cute happy lunch everybody hi i'm hannah
i'm the world's okaiest mom and you know
that i like to shake things up when it
comes to food in my house i let my older
boys meal plan our week a while back and
it has been so highly requested that i
do it again this time with henry i
figured it's time to try it so for an
entire week i'm gonna let the kids meal
plan all of the meals wish me luck
before i go into the meals in case you
haven't noticed we're in a new house one
day i will do a house tour
when the house is clean so it might be a
while so just like last time the only
rule this time is it has to be edible we
can't
eat dirt grass bugs well there are some
edible bugs
so i guess that's okay and whatever the
boys choose is going to be our whole
family's meal including me and matt
and i might regret that okay so do you
guys remember when i let you meal plan a
whole week
you know who wasn't a part of that
henry so we're gonna do it again are you
gonna pick the foods
[Music]
like ice cream i gave the kids a
notebook and i told them to brainstorm i
wrote little categories for them of
breakfast lunch and dinner for each day
jackson was really intense about this
this was like his time to shine
you're taking this very seriously you
want for breakfast
a blue ride
good morning
for this morning's breakfast the only
thing written down let me show you is
the word
french
but i know why i wrote this
and so i know he wants french toast yeah
french toast i always add a little
cinnamon and sugar to my french toast
batter whoopsies i overdid it i'm using
wheat bread oh wow so the theme of this
week is poor planning i realized i don't
have syrup i'm gonna have to make
whipped cream but that's okay because if
you follow me on tik tok you know what
matt surprised me with
my new
toy my new child my child who never
talks back to me my beloved kitchenaid
stand mixer this is not sponsored but
honestly
they should because i love it so much
i'm just so excited everybody loves
french toast everybody was happy with it
i think they were fine with the whipped
cream on top and it was delicious it's
lunchtime and wyatt requested caesar
salad but i don't have croutons and he
is very insistent on having croutons so
i'm gonna try to make them because how
hard could it be right famous last words
i only have sandwich bread so that's
probably my first mistake i'm gonna
sprinkle these with a little salt and
garlic powder
and bake them in the oven these turned
out really good i will never buy
croutons again because they're so much
better than store-bought
wow what do you think you might notice
that wyatt has literally no teeth i
don't know how this happened he just
lost like all of them at once
that was croutons
good really soft actually man i love the
really soft and crunchy ones tonight's
dinner is surprisingly simple not too
much to report here i'm just making
spaghetti no spaghetti tacos no
spaghetti sandwiches i was a little
disappointed that it wasn't very
creative i am out of parmesan oh hi
i am out of parmesan cheese
so i'm using like a cheese blend i don't
know how is it wyatt
big noodle bite
the last thing on the menu today
pretty good dinner wyatt good choice i'm
half ready i have a shoot today didn't
realize
i
have my mascara on
i'm supposed to make smoothie bowls this
morning uh per jackson's request so i'm
going to try to do this really fast
because i'm getting ready and i gotta
start i make smoothie bowls as basically
just a really thick smoothie and then i
put it in a bowl they're kind of a pain
they're kind of messy but they love them
so much so i wasn't surprised to see it
on the meal plan
today for lunch i'm making this
prosciutto pasta that jackson is
obsessed with and my sister gabby makes
it and i've tried to
recreate it and he always says i didn't
do it right so i'm going to try again he
gave me some notes he's a food
connoisseur you know all of a sudden a
couple meals around the world now he
thinks he knows everything all right i
ordered butter because i don't have
butter and it's taking forever so i
think i'm just gonna have to scrap it
and use olive oil i'm a little bit
disappointed because i do really love
buttered noodles
but i think it'll be good with the olive
oil
why how do you like it
okay dinner time and it is jackson's
request of steak mashed potatoes and
broccoli all right we got the steak
roasting
we got mashed potatoes on the warmer and
my broccoli they're all slapping each
other what is going on
tada what do you think
mashed potatoes my favorite
good job
good morning
i'm making breakfast
cookies
so
i'm just kind of winging this so i'm
just improvising i'm throwing everything
in bull oats peanut butter
um applesauce eggs
a little brown sugar i don't know it
kind of looks like crusty
oh i was gonna say crusty balls but that
sounds gross
crumbly mounds oh geez that doesn't
sound good either
they would be good
i put lemon extract and i'm forgetting
i'd put peanut butter in
[Music]
it was honestly one of the most
disgusting things i've ever eaten so
of course i fed it to my kids is it hot
okay he likes it i still like it though
mama you still like it's a little sour
he's doing lessons
[Music]
that's good he did not seem to notice
[Music]
that's really good
you're lying you know it is it's a
peanut butter yeah
it's good
is it so good
[Music]
or just good
you're amazing they're so amazing so
matt learned a new word now he's saying
it's amazing
so
so good old news amazing
yes
hello
today's lunch pancakes and you want your
pancakes to be a little lumpy did you
know that i learned my lesson from the
french toast and i got syrup for these
pancakes what did you think
it was amazing wow you look cool
henry what do you think of the food
thumbs up
[Music]
good job
dinner time
and it's wyatt's request again and
tonight's dinner is cherry tomato salad
sounds very unlike wyatt but this my
friends is what we like to call
personal growth he has discovered that
he loves cherry tomatoes so
i'm gonna make them for him sometimes on
instagram i'll be like hey i'm just
here's how i make a salad and i'm making
the salad and then a bunch of the
comments will be like
oh those knives aren't sharp or
whoa her nose skills suck and i just
i just want to take my hands i want to
cup their precious face and i want to
whisper
real close i know
i know
i know my knives aren't sharp
it's called being lazy
and i don't know if you took a wrong
turn
but this isn't a knife skills class
i'm just making a freaking salad
oh wow pretty
sal is looking good
got mozzarella tomato
artichoke hearts and olives cherry
tomatoes only and some butter lettuce
sad sad garlic bread
because i don't have parsley what do you
think
[Music]
the salad did you try the cherry tomato
[Music]
henry what do you think
you're a great eater
[Music]
matt what do you think
it's really amazing
[Music]
good morning
so i'm headed out but i can make
a breakfast request before i go which is
jackson's he wants toast and the way he
likes it is with
butter and jam
thank you
[Music]
today's lunch we're making bento lunches
of course i couldn't find any actual
bento boxes in the desert so this is
what i'm using so i'm going to do some
cheese sandwiches sliced up really cute
some sliced veggies really cute maybe
some applesauce
look how cute i'm nothing against these
i just don't like doing them because
it's so much time and effort but it is
fun every once in a while
so let's see how this turns out henry's
in my shoes you all know what i'm eating
for lunch
subscribe all right this looks pretty
cute and why do you think
it looks really cute i like the star
sandwiches what do you think why
wow
a man of so many words star cheese watch
this cucumber
i need to make dinner henry's crying at
me even though it's his dinner choice
that we're making tonight and all it
says is quesadillas and ice cream i just
made a really simple cheese quesadilla
are you
enjoying henry what do you think
vote i love it
solid pretty good i used all the ice
cream with the spaghetti dinner but
luckily we had popsicles and nobody
noticed so so far so good and pretty
nutritious now i know that anytime i get
too confident or feel too good about a
food challenge the next day is about to
bite me in the butt good morning
today's breakfast is a henry special and
all it says is blue one i was trying to
figure out a way to make something blue
without using food coloring and so my
first thought was frozen blueberries and
i figured a nice breakfast food is
crepes so i blended the frozen
blueberries with a little bit of water
and i strained that and put it in my
crepe batter it's like very very faintly
blue whoa
that looks really good but here's the
blue one i felt very accomplished after
this dish henry
loved these that's the blue one
[Music]
more blue yeah
amazing
all right for lunch they wanted japanese
bento so i ordered from the only
japanese restaurant we have and i got a
few different types of sushi and then i
made yakisoba noodles how are you liking
your japanese bunto
it's not real japanese funtao though
wyatt is a sushi guy he loves sushi and
so does henry apparently
[Music]
heck ass to this lunch
that night it was ribs baby ribs
your plate look this is the dinner you
requested
i make good ribs that is one thing that
i can claim
look at him mowing down that corn what
do you think guys
this is really tasty dinner
henry loves food that he can pick up and
feed himself like an adult so he loves
ribs he loves corn on the cob like he
loves it hello
i'm missing ingredients
so
this morning's supposed to be waffles
and whipped cream and cherry
[Music]
i have no whipped cream coffee coffee
coffee can't do anything without my
coffee
you know where we can get waffles
[Music]
oh i know i hopped ihop
not sponsored but we love ihop okay i
ordered ihop
i'm sorry i'm just
i'm so tired of cooking
and luckily
they have the family feast perfection
i'm so excited to serve this up it comes
with so much food
it's total enough whipped cream
i'm sorry i'm failing
oh henry are you enjoying
how do you like your brookie
good thank you you're welcome
i love ihop scrambled eggs
[Music]
okay it's lunchtime and jackson
requested
loaded sandwiches i sliced and toasted a
large italian loaf and then i got a ton
of condiments to put on this sandwich
so i did turkey and ham and gouda cheese
with mayo mustard pickles
black olives
pepper cheese romaine and i bought
tomatoes to slice on it and then i
completely forgot to use them which is
just
classic hannah at the end it was a
monstrosity of a sandwich i should have
known because i was just piling stuff on
this looks fantastic oh jackson got hard
eyes the second he saw this sandwich it
was a love at first sight connection
is my mouth big enough you might have to
squeeze it wyatt on the other hand
really struggled to eat it he ended up
deconstructing it but overall it was a
fantastic sandwich dinner is burgers and
shakes per jackson's request i just
couldn't do it i was so tired so
i decided to order those in i don't
think it's cheating because i still
served what was on the menu yeah i can't
compete with a lot of the restaurants
milkshakes so i'm not even going to try
how's dinner guys
[Music]
great choice guys look at that
that looks pretty good
today's breakfast is henry's two
henry's two favorite foods in the world
bar
and yogurt
oh okay is it yummy
big bar
see alexa play emma
you're so cute today is a super special
lunch it's henry's request and all he
requested for lunch was the word
emma who is emma wiggle obviously we
can't eat emma for lunch
but i reached out to her on instagram
and i said hi and my son is a huge fan
and would you mind telling me your
favorite lunch and she did she's a
wonderful person so very sweet so she
said her favorite lunch is steamed
veggies and eggs yellow plate for henry
i thought yellow carrots were fitting
too because emma used to be the yellow
wiggle yay do you say thank you emma
thank you emma
oh you say i love you emma
how are you guys enjoying
what do you think guys this is really
good this just might be my new favorite
lunch too all right dinner tonight is
meat and mac and cheese so i seasoned
the brisket with a dry rub put it in the
oven for about an hour took it out added
a broth and then covered it with foil
and put it back in the oven for about
three hours
shall we see
i just painted my nails oh wait i can't
look it's literally covered in foil i
just painted my nails so
and i already messed one up i like i
need to
have a make a confession right now um
this
fake fake
as up she could never she would never
it's fake meat and mac and cheese what
does everybody think these are two of my
kids favorite staple foods they were
really happy and we got to end the week
on a high note so compared to the last
time we did this i felt like this meal
plan was a little more conventional and
a lot more
home cooking heavy i think as my kids
get older their taste maybe refines a
bit i think henry is definitely the wild
card which kept it creative kept it
exciting will i do this again
maybe in another three years i'll
definitely appreciate that you urged me
to try this again i wasn't really
feeling that inspired and this really
reignited my love for cooking and being
silly with it and i just really
appreciate that so that's all for now
i'm hannah and what did you think of
this
second time around meal plan what did
you think of henry's meals
did you like your meals
[Music]
yummy so should we do this again let us
know should we do it again yeah okay
stay till next time
bye
[Music]
you